I'm going to enter that slightly gloomy house
Kimura-kun, I won't
wait.It's late.You can only stay here for 37 minutes.
Ahaha j I witnessed Kimura's date coordination at 36 o'clock
.
No, let's proceed with the dating experiment as soon as
possible exe hm
[music]
Freshness is not a target in terms of time, huh.
[Music]
Which do you think is better, Dokin shoes
?  Then
, based on the priority, we define ex, which expresses the quality of the
shoes.Based on the priority, the definition of ex is behavioral.
0.2 + cost multiplied by 0.1 also means that the higher this number, the better the shoes.
A value based on the reciprocal of the price is fine.
Just compare the ab evaluation numbers for the shoes calculated in this way
.